Hi, I'm Tom from the Burp Scanner development team. Today I'm going to talk a little bit about
stored input detection in Burp Scanner. So stored input detection is the process of finding places
in an application where we can submit data that will then be stored by the application,
and then linking that to other places in the application where we can retrieve that data.
This is different from something like reflected input detection, which is just finding data which
is reflected in the immediate response to a request. So stored data detection is really
important because stored or second order vulnerabilities tend to have on average a
lot higher severity than their reflected or first order counterparts. This is because an attacker can
just plant payloads in the application and wait for victims to find them rather than having to rely on
a separate delivery mechanism. So how does Burp Scanner do stored input detection? If we hop into Burp here
I've got a scan that I've already run so that we don't have to sit and watch it. If I go ahead and
open up the view details tab and head over to the audit items we can see here that there are multiple
active phases. So in the first phase we do all of our first order checks. In the second phase we
generate unique payloads and send them to every insertion point and every request. In the third
phase we send every request again and look for those unique payloads from phase two in all of the responses.
In phase four we do all of our second order checks. So in a lot of cases these are functionally identical to
our first order checks. We just hide the fact that there's more going on between the request and response
to the scan check that's doing the scan checking. In the fifth phase we send all of our
collaborative collaborator based blind XSS payloads to every insertion point. So phases two and three are what make of our
stored input detection and phase four uses these stored data paths. There is one caveat or limitation
to our stored input detection currently and that's multi-step processes. So this would be something
like an order form that's collecting information across multiple pages and then reflecting all of
your choices back at the end. Because currently we're linking single requests to single responses
and we're not sending all of the requests in that in that process, if we just do step one or two in
isolation and then look at the final step, it's probably going to say something like you've not
done everything required and it's not going to reflect our data back to us. This is something
that's been on our backlog for a very long time. We just haven't come up with a way of doing it that
isn't kind of combinatorial explosive on the number of requests that we'd have to send. So we're working on it and we'll get there.